سنه مياهه اقترحت هذه التعديلات في يناير
الماضي والتي تنص على منح الحكومه نفوذا
صريحا في اختيار القضاه فضلا عن ذلك فان
التعديلات تحد من صلاحيه المحكمه العليا
في الغاء القوانين او اصدار احكام ضد
السلطه التنفيذيه التعديلات تشمل نظام
تعيين قضاه المحكمه العليا كما ذكر الياس
قبل قليل من قبل لجنه تضم قضاه ونواب
ومحامي اما البنت الاكثر جدلا في
التعديلات فيسمح للبرلمان بالغاء بعض
قرارات المحكمه العليا بغالبيه بسيطه تبلغ
واحدا وستين صوتا وتمنع هذه الفقره
المحكمه العليا من الغاء قوانين الا في
حال اجتماع جميع قضاتها الخمسه عشر وتاييد
12 منهم للقرار وكان الكنيستا قد صدق في
وقت سابق بالقراءه الاولى على مشروعي
قانوني قانون احدهما يمنح الائتلاف الحاكم
الاغلبيه في اللجنه الخاصه بتعيين القدع
اما القانون الثاني فيمنع المحكمه العليا
من الغاء قوانين قوانين اساس سنها الكنيست
الاسرائيلي